I would safely say yeah my bullet Ector
is pretty good by telltale signs of an
underage person typically you get the
person who is very edgy when they show
up and they really don't know exactly
how things work and they're kind of just
anxious for no reason and then of course
they hesitate 'only hands you their ID
and they kind of just sit there and
smile their body language most people
are pretty good at lying but their body
isn't when they're walking up they're
here and no eye contact usually I find
that people will stand up straight and
they're like yes that's me and they'll
look at the card whereas the other one
here you go and kind of look away so I
mean those are just some of the signs
there's certain things on one ID that's
real that you won't find on a fake ID
and if it and vice versa some of the
things we look for when we're looking
for a fake ID would definitely be
laminated pieces of plastic or pieces of
paper that have absolutely zero traits
of an actual ID
most ladies do have like a special
actual tag that you can see a certain
lighting here in California is if you
have a light you have the California
bear outline in the back and if you hold
it up you can see that outline of where
as the fakes tend to not happen well
actually at my first job in 2011 a
couple either blatantly not recognizing
their surroundings or deliberately not
caring and starting to get it on while
other people are around so I had to
politely tell them hey look this is not
the spot for that I feel you have a good
time move it on take it elsewhere I've
seen a lot of people hook up pretty much
wherever they can get it in and seeing
that on I would say everyday basis is
not really crazy anymore it's just the
norm to me now
starting a fight and probably stripping
just getting naked undermining the fact
that we're here and we're doing a job
and we're here to do a job and making
sure that you're allowing us to do so
get out of line and try to be aggressive
with you for no reason it does happen
you get macho people whether it's women
or men we just have a bad attitude and
want to take it out on you someone not
having their forms of ID like they
should and you know just trying to kind
of talk me up oh you're so handsome
you're so cute it's like um appreciate
the compliment but uh you know I still
need that form of idea if you don't mind
honestly like pet names and things like
that are probably the easiest way to
piss me off yeah those things like Big
Boi Big John
accurate first impressions coming up to
the door always make a huge statement
being polite you actually don't have to
say much to a bouncer just make sure you
have your ID card probably just being
prepared and not having a bunch of
[ __ ] that you're with
don't be getting out of line just have a
good time and don't be destructive or
disruptive and causing a scene the best
excuse I've ever gotten for forgetting
an ID was definitely they said their dog
ate it which we all know is [ __ ] [ __ ]
literally the worst excuse you could say
is I forgot my ID there's no excuses for
forgetting it just just bring it most
likely not but depending on the
situation every situation is different
and sometimes it can be really and
possibly be let back in but in most
instances if you're escorted out you're
not coming back I would say the book
detector that I have is pretty on par
and you'd be lucky if you get away with
something I would safely say yeah
detector is pretty good by now I'm
working on it I'm working on it but I'd
like to think it's pretty good probably
about a B plus a minus without so we got
my other security officers here for to
help me when I may miss a certain thing
there have to pick me back up
you could get to the front of the line
as long as you had a pretty good
standing relationship with the person
that was actually at the door I plead
the fifth on that anyway to get to the
fertile land as if you know the owner
that would pretty much be the only thing
everyone else is treated the exact same
way here for me one of the best parts of
the job is the fact that I get to be
around music people I do like to dance
and sing myself so being around the
environment is always good for me
getting to meet new people in here and
having them kind of trust in you as the
security guide to say that they trust
that you're there to protect you're
going to do the right thing definitely
the social interaction part of it making
sure that you're meeting plenty of
people from all around the world but
also being a part of keeping them safe
as well
[Music]